And the answer is no. So even path coverage's stronger criteria
that we saw is not enough to reveal this problem. And why
is that? So let me go back to a concept that
I mentioned in a previous lesson, the cost of exhaustive testing. Exhaustive
testing is really the only way in which we can exercise
all of the possible behaviors of a program. So we can say
even though it might sound like topology, that only exhaustive testing is
exhausted. All the coverage criteria that we saw are just process and
just approximation of a complete test. So test is a best effort kind
of activity. Coverage criteria help you assess
how well you tested but once more,
test can only reveal issues, can only reveal problems. You can never show the
absence of problems. And that's something is
important to remember when we do testing.